(Transcrito por TurboScribe. Atualize para Ilimitado para remover esta mensagem.) Nessa aula nós vamos falar sobre a desocupação
de um imóvel em leilão judicial.
A desocupação de um imóvel em leilão judicial,
ela tem um procedimento mais facilitado do que
a desocupação no leilão extrajudicial.
No leilão extrajudicial, a gente já viu no
módulo 2 que caso você como arrematante não
consiga um acordo de desocupação com quem está
ocupando aquele imóvel, você deve entrar com uma
ação de emissão na posse.
Então você vai fazer esse pedido para o
juiz, que ele vai definir, eliminar, determinando um
prazo de até 60 dias para que a
pessoa saia voluntariamente do imóvel e se a
pessoa não sair, vai ocorrer a desocupação forçada.
Aqui no leilão judicial, a desocupação, ela não
precisa dessa ação de emissão na posse.
Por quê?
Porque o leilão judicial aconteceu dentro de um
processo judicial.
Então esse processo judicial já existe.
Basta que o arrematante vá diretamente nesse processo
judicial para o mesmo juiz que ordenou o
leilão e faça o requerimento do mandado de
emissão na posse.
A gente vai estudar um pouco mais à
frente aqui nesse módulo como é que funciona
o procedimento pós-leilão.
E uma das partes que eu vou falar
é que depois do leilão, o arrematante, ele
deve fazer um requerimento ao juiz pedindo a
carta de arrematação.
A carta de arrematação, ela é o documento
que vai possibilitar que o arrematante faça o
registro do imóvel em seu nome.
Em leilão judicial, não existe escritura de comprovenda.
A carta de arrematação fica no lugar dessa
escritura de comprovenda que não vai existir em
leilão judicial.
Quando o arrematante, ele faz esse pedido da
carta de arrematação, ele também vai fazer o
pedido do mandado de emissão na posse.
E eu vou deixar esses modelos todos na
aula de procedimento pós-leilão, assim como eu
fiz no módulo 2.
Você vai poder preencher esse modelo, levar a
um advogado que você escolha para o advogado
protocolar esse modelo no processo judicial.
Queria fazer duas observações aqui.
Existem juízes que aceitam que o arrematante sem
advogado faça esse requerimento da carta de arrematação
e do mandado de emissão na posse.
E existem juízes que não aceitam.
Via de regra, o juiz, ele não vai
aceitar, porque quem tem capacidade postulatória, que é
a capacidade de atuar em juízo, pela lei
é o advogado.
Então, a maioria dos juízes, eles não aceitam.
Mas esse procedimento, ele é muito mais facilitado
do que uma ação de emissão na posse,
como acontece no leilão excrediticial.
Então, provavelmente, você como arrematante, se você não
for advogado, você vai precisar de um advogado
para que ele faça esse requerimento da carta
de arrematação e do mandado de emissão na
posse.
E aqui queria deixar a primeira observação.
Esse advogado, ele tende a te cobrar bem
menos do que para fazer uma ação de
emissão na posse de um leilão excrediticial.
Exatamente porque no leilão judicial, o processo já
existe, o processo já está correndo e é
o mesmo juiz que vai determinar a desocupação.
Então, o trabalho do advogado, ele é bem
facilitado.
Ele vai num processo que já existe para
o mesmo juiz que determinou e vai fazer
esse pedido.
Não é a mesma coisa do que uma
ação de emissão na posse, que não existe
um processo.
Então, o advogado, ele teria que fazer, desde
o começo, um processo.
Então, aqui no leilão judicial, o advogado, ele
tende a te cobrar menos e eu acredito
que com o modelo que eu vou disponibilizar
na aula de procedimento pós-leilão, esse advogado
vai te cobrar ainda menos, porque você vai
preencher o que aconteceu naquele caso, qual foi
o dia da arrematação, o valor da arrematação,
os seus dados e vai pedir para um
advogado protocolar esse requerimento no processo.
E a segunda observação, apesar de já existir
um processo judicial, apesar do mesmo juiz ele
determinar a expedição da carta de arrematação e
desse mandado de emissão na posse, o juiz,
ele não faz isso automaticamente.
Você, como arrematante, você precisa desse requerimento.
Por quê?
Porque o juiz, ele nunca age de ofício.
Existe um princípio no processo judicial que exatamente
fala isso, que o poder judiciário, ele deve
ser provocado para agir.
Então o juiz, ele só faz qualquer ato
se você provocar que ele faça aquele ato.
Então você deve fazer o requerimento e aí
sim o juiz vai determinar que seja expedida
a carta de arrematação e o mandado de
emissão na posse.
Então vamos lá, voltando para desocupação de um
imóvel em leilão judicial.
O juiz vai determinar então que seja expedido
esse mandado de emissão na posse e esse
mandato que vai proporcionar a desocupação de um
imóvel que foi arrematado em um leilão judicial.
É comum que num primeiro momento que ele
espeça esse mandado de emissão na posse, mas
que ele coloque um prazo para desocupação voluntária.
Por exemplo, o ocupante tem dez dias para
sair do imóvel e após isso a desocupação
vai acontecer de forma forçada.
Então o ocupante teria dez dias para desocupar
aquele imóvel de forma voluntária, nesses dez dias
ele poderia sair no dia que ele bem
entendesse, na medida que ele não cumprir esse
prazo de desocupação voluntária, a desocupação seria forçada.
E também é comum que mesmo que o
juiz não estabeleça esse prazo de desocupação voluntária,
que o próprio oficial de justiça que vai
cumprir a desocupação forçada, ele entre em contato
antes com o ocupante e comunique.
Olha, eu vou cumprir esse mandado de emissão
na posse no dia tal e até esse
dia o ocupante poderia se programar para sair
de forma voluntária.
O que acontece na maioria dos casos?
O ocupante quando ele ganha esse prazo de
desocupação voluntária ou quando o próprio oficial de
justiça comunica que vai cumprir a desocupação em
tal dia, ele já se programa para sair
antes.
Então é normal que o oficial de justiça
chegue ao imóvel e que o imóvel já
esteja desocupado, a pessoa saiu voluntariamente antes.
Agora, se isso não acontecer, vai ser cumprida
a chamada desocupação forçada.
O que significa essa desocupação forçada?
O ocupante está normalmente no imóvel com todos
os seus móveis, com sua família e o
oficial de justiça ele vai comparecer e aquela
desocupação vai ser realizada de qualquer maneira.
Caso o oficial de justiça não te comunique
antes que aconteceu uma desocupação voluntária, você como
arrematante vai ter que disponibilizar um caminhão de
mudança para o dia dessa desocupação forçada, porque
se o oficial de justiça chegar lá e
o ocupante está normalmente no imóvel com todos
os seus móveis, ele vai efetivamente determinar que
a desocupação aconteça contra a vontade do ocupante.
Ele pode inclusive pedir auxílio da polícia para
que aquela desocupação aconteça e para realizar a
desocupação vai ter que tirar todos os móveis
daquele ocupante de dentro do imóvel.
Então por isso que o arrematante nesses casos
deve disponibilizar um caminhão de mudança para que
os móveis possam ser retirados do imóvel e
ser levado para algum outro lugar.
E aí nesse caso vai ser levado para
onde o ocupante indicar, geralmente o ocupante vai
falar eu quero que leve a minha mudança
para o endereço tal e aí você vai
comunicar ao caminhão de mudança que você contratou
que vai levar para tal endereço.
Agora, existe a possibilidade do ocupante não indicar
um lugar para levar os móveis ou que
o ocupante, se ele fizer uma proposta absurda,
por exemplo, a desocupação aconteceu no Rio de
Janeiro, ele fale que ele quer levar essa
mudança para a Bahia.
Você como arrematante não é responsável por realizar
essa transição de estado, você só é responsável
por tirar aqueles móveis ali e deixar em
algum lugar mais próximo possível.
Então, caso o ocupante não indique um lugar
ou caso o ocupante indique algo absurdo, você
deve providenciar um depósito, esses depósitos de móveis
que existem.
Então você vai levar essa mudança para um
depósito e aí o ocupante depois deve retirar
essa mudança do depósito e se ele não
fizer essa retirada em até 90 dias, você
pode considerar aquilo ali como abandono e aí
você faz o que você quiser com aqueles
móveis.
Comunique ao juiz, fale que ele não tirou
e que a partir daquele momento você vai
dispor daqueles móveis.
Qual é a probabilidade de você precisar de
um depósito para botar a mudança?
Bastíssima, particularmente eu nunca vi isso acontecer, porque
sair de um imóvel através de uma desocupação
forçada já não é algo agradável e ainda
depois ter que ter os seus móveis levados
para um depósito que o ocupante não conhece
aquele depósito é ainda mais traumático.
Via de regra, quando acontece uma desocupação forçada,
o ocupante vai indicar eu quero que os
meus móveis sejam levados para o endereço de
um imóvel da minha família ou de um
amigo que eu possa ficar lá por enquanto.
Então precisar de um depósito é algo muito
muito raro, eu particularmente nunca vi acontecer como
eu falei.
É importante que ao requerer esse mandado de
missão na posse, o arrematante peça que conste
nesse mandado inclusive uma ordem de arrombamento.
O que significa essa ordem de arrombamento?
O ocupante não saiu voluntariamente, vai ter que
realizar a desocupação forçada.
Agora imagine que essa desocupação vai ser realizada
em um prédio, esse imóvel que você arrematou
é um apartamento, então chega o oficial de
justiça na portaria daquele prédio, a portaria vai
interfonar para aquele apartamento e ninguém atende.
É importante que o oficial de justiça ele
tenha uma ordem muito clara que ele vai
poder entrar naquele imóvel de qualquer maneira e
essa ordem é essa ordem de arrombamento.
Arrombar não significa literalmente você chegar no imóvel,
enfiar o pé na porta e abrir aquela
porta de maneira brutal, até porque isso para
você como arrematante seria um prejuízo que depois
você vai ter que consertar aquela porta.
Então quando tem essa ordem de arrombamento no
mandado de missão na posse, o arrematante ele
deve providenciar também um chaveiro.
Então o chaveiro que o arrematante providenciar vai
chegar naquele imóvel e vai abrir aquele imóvel
normalmente e você como arrematante já aproveita para
trocar a chave, o miolo daquela fechadura, para
garantir que só você tenha a chave daquele
imóvel dali em diante.
Então recapitulando, o juiz ele vai determinar esse
mandado de missão na posse, esse mandado de
missão na posse ele vai ser cumprido por
um oficial de justiça e caso não ocorra
a desocupação voluntária, seja no prazo que o
próprio juiz concedeu ou seja na comunicação do
oficial de justiça falando que iria cumprir aquela
determinação em tal dia.
Se o ocupante não sair, ocorre a desocupação
forçada.
O oficial de justiça vai comparecer pessoalmente e
vai realizar aquela desocupação de qualquer maneira.
Pro caso de uma desocupação forçada, você como
arrematante deve disponibilizar um caminhão de mudança e
até mesmo um chaveiro para que se o
ocupante não abrir a porta daquele imóvel de
livre espontânea vontade, seja feita a ordem de
arrombamento que vai ser feita por um chaveiro
de sua confiança.
Você como arrematante deve saber qual é o
dia que o oficial de justiça vai cumprir
aquela desocupação, até para que você possa providenciar
um caminhão e um chaveiro se for o
caso, se a pessoa não deixar voluntariamente aquele
imóvel.
Como é que você vai saber esse dia?
O oficial de justiça é um servidor público
que na maioria do tempo ele está na
rua, ele não está nas dependências do fórum,
exatamente porque ele precisa cumprir todas as determinações
que os juízes fazem, então ele passa pouquíssimo
tempo no fórum.
Para ser mais específico, a regra é que
o oficial de justiça que ele tenha um
dia de plantão num fórum e todos os
outros dias ele fique na rua.
Então você como arrematante muito provavelmente vai ter
um advogado, porque eu falei anteriormente que a
capacidade postulatória é de um advogado, então via
de regra os juízes só aceitam que esses
requerimentos sejam feitos por um advogado.
Então você como arrematante vai ter um advogado,
mas se você não tiver eu vou falar
como é que funciona tudo caso você queira
fazer sozinho e o juiz te permita fazer
sozinho.
Você deve entrar em contato com a central
dos oficiais de justiça, perguntar qual é o
oficial de justiça que vai cumprir especificamente o
mandado de missão na posse do seu imóvel
e entrar em contato diretamente com o oficial
de justiça.
Quando você entra em contato com essa central
dos oficiais, geralmente ou eles falam que o
oficial de justiça fica no dia tal, de
tal a tal hora e aí você pode
comparecer nesse dia que é o plantão dele
no fórum e falar diretamente com ele ou
até mesmo eles falam qual é o telefone
do oficial de justiça.
Então você vai entrar em contato direto com
o oficial de justiça por telefone e vai
perguntar qual é o dia que você vai
cumprir esse mandado para que eu possa programar
uma mudança, para que eu possa programar uma
chaveira.
Ele vai te informar e a partir daí
você vai programar a desocupação daquele imóvel.
Algo que você também precisa saber, o arrematante
ou alguém que represente o arrematante ele deve
comparecer no dia da desocupação do imóvel.
Se você tiver um advogado, quem vai comparecer
é o seu advogado.
Ele vai comparecer e vai acompanhar aquela desocupação.
Se você estiver agindo sozinho, você mesmo ou
alguém que você passe uma procuração vai poder
te representar naquele dia.
Então vamos supor que a desocupação vai acontecer
num dia que você não possa comparecer ou
que você arrematou esse imóvel e você mora
em outra cidade, você mora em Porto Alegre
e você arrematou esse imóvel aqui em São
Paulo.
Você pode passar uma procuração para que alguém
te represente no dia da desocupação.
Por fim, então, só para falar que esses
comentários de chaveiro, caminhão de mudança, eles também
se aplicam na ação de missão na posse
no leilão ex-credencial, porque vai acontecer a
mesma coisa.
Vai sair uma determinação do juiz determinando a
desocupação daquele imóvel, se não for cumprido em
prazo voluntário, vai ser desocupação forçada e aí
o trâmite é todo igual.
O oficial de justiça vai comparecer, vai realizar
a desocupação, pode ter ordem de arrombamento, pode
precisar de um caminhão de mudança, vale tudo
igual para leilão ex-credencial e leilão judicial.
Eu falei no leilão ex-credencial que era
muito interessante que o arrematante ele fizesse um
acordo para a desocupação acontecer de forma pacífica
sem precisar do poder judiciário.
Isso no leilão ex-credencial é algo muito
interessante, porque nesse caso o arrematante nem mesmo
precisaria de um advogado e ele encurtaria muito
o prazo de desocupação daquele imóvel se ele
chegasse a nenhum inconsenso com quem está ocupando.
Eu falei que é interessante que você faça
um acordo até mesmo estipulando o valor do
caminhão de mudança ou estipulando um primeiro aluguel,
o que ficar aqui ao seu critério.
Como é que vale para o leilão judicial?
No leilão judicial, como você como arrematante já
vai ter que ingressar no processo de qualquer
maneira, porque vai ser assim que você vai
conseguir sua carta de arrematação, você pode muito
bem falar eu não quero fazer acordo nenhum,
eu tenho que entrar no processo.
Uma vez que eu vou entrar no processo
para pedir a carta de arrematação, eu vou
pedir o mandato de admissão na posse e
deixo o oficial de justiça cumprir esse mandato
de admissão na posse.
Não quero fazer acordo nenhum.
É seu direito, você tem toda a opção
de fazer isso.
Agora eu só queria te lembrar de uma
coisa.
A gente falou aqui que na desocupação forçada,
você vai precisar de um caminhão de mudança.
Então você vai precisar de qualquer forma pagar
aquela mudança, se a pessoa se recusar a
sair e precisar de uma desocupação forçada.
Então mesmo em leilão judicial, pode ser vantagem
que você entre em contato com a pessoa
que está ocupando aquele imóvel e fale, olha,
eu pago sua mudança, você sai em 15
dias, você sai em 20 dias e a
gente não precisa passar por esse constrangimento de
um oficial de justiça comparecer e te botar
para fora a força do imóvel, precisar de
auxílio da polícia, precisar de um chaveiro para
abrir a porta.
Resolve isso de maneira pacífica, fica a seu
critério ou não.
Pode ser que você entenda que uma vez
que vai ingressar no processo, deixa o oficial
de justiça cumprir, ou pode ser que você
entenda, eu vou entrar no processo, vou pedir
a carta de arrematação, vou pedir o mandado
de admissão na posse, mas nesse meio tempo
entre o oficial de justiça cumprir, eu vou
ver se a pessoa sai pacificamente, se oferecer
o valor da mudança, se ela sai de
forma mais rápida.
Isso aí fica a seu critério como arrematante.
Vou dar a minha opinião particular.
Se a pessoa falar que com o pagamento
de uma mudança ela sai daquele imóvel rapidamente,
eu faço pagamento da mudança, isso não vai
impactar no lucro.
Uma mudança mais cara custa em torno de
800 reais, se for uma mudança mais barata,
um frete desses de rua, você consegue pagar
bem menos.
É algo que pode trazer um benefício que
você não precisa comparecer ou se fazer representar
no dia da desocupação.
Isso fica a seu critério.
Na prática ali, você vai ver como é
que vai ser melhor, como é que não
vai ser, se você quer ou não ter
um contato com o ocupante, se você não
quiser, você deixa pro oficial de justiça fazer,
tudo certo, você escolhe.
Aqui no Leilão de Edicel você tem ainda
mais opção porque a desocupação já vai ser
cumprida por um oficial de justiça, então você
se optar, você não precisa nem entrar em
contato com o ocupante, o oficial de justiça
ele faz tudo.